NBA legend Michael Jordan announced he's
launching his own brand of tequila in
partnership with the owner of the Lakers
Celtics and the Bucs that's right pretty
interesting what do you think Andy
Michael Jordan tequila it just it seems
like kind of a gross cash grab what do
you mean oh I mean a bunch of rich
sports dudes slapping their names on
liquor to make more money I mean come on
what is Michael Jordan know about the
fine art of transforming the essence of
the agave plant into a world-class
tequila forging the Sun and the heat of
the Mexican desert into liquid gold oh
you're right Andy those jocks probably
no no no the first thing about carefully
selecting the finest blue agave plants
grown in the volcanic soil of illegal
then using time-honored traditions to
purify the nectar drop by drop until you
find that sweet spot between silkiness
five
yeah are you thinking what I'm thinking
I think I am
[Music]
Conan and Andy's Michael Jordan tequila
and slam-dunk
everytime imported by wrinkles a greedy
[Applause]